unsere broker erlebt gerade so was wie
den perfekten sturm corona plus rückkehr
der flüchtlingskrise an der
türkisch-griechischen grenze spielen
sich weiter dramatische szenen ab von
erdogan benutzte migranten hängen fest
im niemandsland zynischer geht's
wirklich nicht immerhin hatte der
türkische präsident jetzt einen tollen
tipp für seine geliebten nachbarn
riesenland warum macht wenig teurer tore
auf lasst sie nach europa ziehen so wie
wir denn seit ihr silos griechenland ja
einfach aufmachen die tür nach dem alten
karnevalsmotto die karawane zieht weiter
dem sultan ist wurscht erdogans
masterplan also mit flüchtlingen mehr eu
kohle erpressen ist noch nicht
aufgegangen und auch seine bremens mit
wladimir putin steckt in einer art
liebeskrise der russe hat ihnen beim
staatsbesuch in moskau sogar regelrecht
gedemütigt haben sie es gesehen live im
russischen staatsfernsehen
hier spaziert der erdogan noch fröhlich
in putins vorzimmer und dann merkte aber
dass der zar von russland ihn eiskalt
warten lässt putin musste nämlich noch
fertig frühstücken lecker hüttenkäse
recep denkt sich so noch eine minute
dann auch ich aber ab arschloch derweil
putin mensch ich habe ja ewig kein
papier mehr gespielt doodle diedeldei in
der zwischenzeit muss er sich hinsetzen
ja klar sondern alter diktator ist ja
kein b zugleich computing aber oder noch
nicht er schwimmt 800 meter freistil
weltrekord und gerade als erde endgültig
in russland marschieren will vor wut
öffnen sich endlich die türen und es
gibt ein happy end ja gut ding sagt
balte säule wo bleibst du denn ich habe
nebenan auf dich gewartet
man man man ewig im wartezimmer gesessen
das war wirklich ernst ganz persönliches
stalingrad bei diesem besuch ja wegen
putins bomben sind immer noch eine
million syrische flüchtlinge aus der
provinz idlib auf der flucht und der
westen steht hilflos daneben hilflos
also bis auf unseren außenminister
natürlich ein koma
der gibt diesen kriegsverbrechern aber
richtig zunder logisch
der un sicherheitsrat kann und muss mehr
tun um das leiden zu beenden
wir müssen endlich unsere bemühungen
verdoppeln eine politische lösung zu
finden
doppelte bemühungen da tut ihn direkt zu
es hat gesagt alter wir müssen sofort
mit bomben aufhören der al-ko verdoppelt
seine bemühung ja das ist die rolle von
deutschland und europa steht der wald
schweigend daneben wenn griechenland mal
eben für einen monat das grundrecht auf
asyl abschafft ja ich sage ihnen wenn
die eu so weitermacht erfüllt sie bald
nicht mehr die beitrittsbedingungen für
die eu andere soll für uns gefälligst
die dreckarbeit machen ob sache weit weg
sogar die erfinderin der
willkommenskultur gibt das inzwischen
erfrischend ehrlich zu es ist natürlich
unsere aufgabe zuflucht suchenden
menschen in ihrer heimat oder wo das
wegen krieg und verfolgung nicht möglich
ist möglichst nahe ihre heimat
sicherheit und eine perspektive für
bildung ausbildung und arbeit zu geben
verstehen sie da ihre heimat also
möglichst weit weg von unserer heimat ja
nach riesenstreit in der gruppe erklärt
deutschland sich jetzt großzügig bereit
1600 flüchtlingskinder von den
griechischen inseln aufzunehmen toll ich
lese gerade einen angemessenen anteil
davon
und die sollten nach buckow definitionen
kranksein oder unbegleitet unter 14 und
am liebsten mädchen ja alles leider
kennen wir jetzt steht also und dafür
feiert sich die cdu auch noch die feiern
sich dafür das c steht aber schon noch
für christlich oder im nachhinein macht
es ja total sinn dass dieser
greenpeace-aktivisten am konrad adenauer
haus neulich das c geklaut hat sie
brauchen es ja gar nicht mehr
die cdu heißt jetzt nur noch die sinne
von du kommst hier nicht rein also außer
du bist unter 14 unbegleitet und so
weiter bin so gespannt wie die
glücklichen kinder aussuchen das schreit
doch förmlich nach einer rtl castingshow
du bist unter 15 und griechenland
gefällt ihr nicht dann bewirbt sich
jetzt als flüchtlingskind in deutschland
und wir erwarten da gar nicht viel von
dir du musst es nur alle strophen des
erlkönigs fehlerfrei
auch sagen eine brahms sonate auf dem
cello spielen wissen wie man einen
perfekten rollbraten zubereitet und
natürlich wie man ein bier mit den
zähnen auf macht wer bleibt draußen wer
kommt rein
demnächst bei deutschland sucht das
super flüchtlingskind und wir wünschen
an dieser stelle allen kandidatinnen
die leute ich wollte euch nur um ein
kleines auto bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut los hast
du scheiße fährt haye